MATHIAS BYNENS: All right so in ES6 every
regular expression has a Unicode getter that
returns true or false depending on whether
a new flag, the u flag, which stands for Unicode
has been enabled for this regular expression
ornot. That’s pretty much what this presentation
will be about. Fun fact about the title of
this talk, you shouldn't ever run Unicode.
You shouldn't use this code because technically
it should throw an error, Unicode is a getter
that defined in the prototype, but the getter
checks if it's being called on a regular expression
instance, and RegExp type itself is not a
regular expression instance. Just a quick
fun fact.
Anyway, before we get started let's just make
sure we're all onthe same page when it comes
to Unicode I am just going to throw some terminology
at you a couple of terms I will be using throughout
the rest of the presentation. Let's get started.
So the easiest way of to think of Unicode
is kind of like a database that maps any symbol
you can think of to a unique name for that
symbol and a unique canonical, which is a
unique number for that. You have the letter
A which you have the code point U+0041 and
the small letter a which is a completely different
symbol, it gets it own unique name and code
point. This is very useful because it allows
you to refer to a specific symbol without
having to use the symbol itself, you can just
refer to code point or to name, and everyone
can look it up and the Unicode standard and
know exactly which symbol you are talking
about.
Now, code points are usually formatted the
way you see here you get the u+ prefix then
following by a number of hexadecimal digits,
upto at least 4 hexadecimal digits as well.
There's a bunch of code points in Unicode
forexample there's also the pile of poo
and many other emoji, and really the code
points in Unicode span avery wide range,
there’s a lot of them. It goes all the way
from 0 to 10 FFF so that's a little over 1.1
million different code points. Now to keep
thing a little bit organised Unicode divides
these code points up into 17 so called planes
I am not going to bore you with the details
for each of these individual planes. the first
one is pretty interesting it's called the
basic the multilingual plane or the BMP, it
goes from 0FFFF, Ithink it's the most important
one it contains all the most commonly used
symbols, whenever you are writing a text document
in English or Spanish or German you probably
won't need any symbols outside of this BMP
range.
Now all the other planes combined theyare
calling the astral planes so they range from
1000 to 10FFFF so the vast majority ofthe
Unicode point space lies in this astral range,
over 95% of all code points are there, but
because the BMP contains all the most important
ones, alot of developers tend to forget
about allthe other code points.
I actually gave a presentation about that
last year, itwas titled ‘JavaScript has
a Unicode problem.’ I explained some of
the problems in JavaScript strings I will
not be able to repeat allthe examples and
explain how you fix them if you are interested
in that just check out the presentation I
gave last year, the link is right there and
justto give you one small example forexample
if you take a string containing only an astral
symbol like the pile of poo emoji forinstance,
it has a length of 2 instead of 1 which may
not be what you expect. This happens because
JavaScript expresses astral symbols as 2 separate
units called surrogate half. That combined
together ina surrogate pair, this represents
a single astral symbol. It's a little bit
confusing. Let's talk about RegExp so there's
a bunch of effects that this new u flag for
regular expressions has, but first that will
discuss isthe impact on syntax. It also
kind of changes the meaning of the .operator,
quantifiers are affected as character classes
have new behaviour, character class escape
have changed the iflag for case in sensitivity
gets a new behaviour when it's combined with
the u flag, even HTML documents are kind of
impacted by the existence of the u flag believe
it ornot, and finally we will take a look
at browser support. Let's get started with
the impact the u flag has on syntax. Adding
the u flag to a regular expression automatically
unlocks a new syntax called Unicode code point
escapes. These things start with a\ followed
by u followed by braces. Between those braces
you can usany number of hexadecimal digits
you want to use a ofcourse you only need
sticks to be ableto rep sensibility any
Unicode point that's plenty. Now this again
makes it really easy to refer to any symbol
with having to use the symbol itself you can
just refer to code point it instead, specially
if youare creating a huge regular expression
that tries to match alot of different code
points or symbols it can make a regular expression
actually more readable if you want to deal
with you probably don't want to look at all
these weird characters in your code you just
want to see the code points instead this makes
that's really ease. In fact this Unicode code
point escapes syntax is automatically available
in string and template strings as well in
ES6 if you want to use it in regular expression
you need to use the u flag first.
In fact if may look like you are already able
to use these code points escapes even without
a u flag but that not really what's going
on. Forexample the code at the bottom doesn't
throw an error which might lead youto believe
it actually already works but it also does
not quite do what you would expect toit.
So in this case the\followed by the u is actually
an unnecessary escape sequence for the u character,
then the braces and numbers rapped in the
braces that the quantifier, instead of matching
the code point U+234 youare basically saying
match the letter U repeat it 1, 2, 3, 4 times.
That’s why you explicitly opt in by using
the u flag if you want to use this feature
it's also a good reason to not blindly go
through your existing source code and blindly
add the u flag to your existing RegExp because
you might end up accidentally changing their
meaning this way.
Now to avoid this kind of ambiguity inthe
future the u flag prevents you from using
unneeded escapes for example the A character
doesn't have any special meaning at regular
expression, so there no reason why you would
want to escape using a \U if you enabled the
U flag for a regular expression. This will
actually throw an error this is JavaScript's
way of warning you, you are doing something
weird here.
So really you can think ofthe u flag as
kind of like a strict mode for RegExp specifically
Ithink you should use is for any new RegExp
you create from now on, but at the same time
you should not blindly go back to your old
source code and just add the u flag to all
your own regular expression without thinking
what you are doing because once again you
accidentally change their meaning ina very
subtle way and possibly break your code.
Now let's talk about the impact on the dot
pop operator. Now without the u flag, dot
matches any BMP symbol without line terminator.
If you use a.bina regular expression, it
won't match the tetragram for sender symbol,
because that's an astral symbol asfaras
JavaScript is concerned, that astral symbol
consists ofthe 2 surrogate halves, it treats
each of them as an individual character. This
is a bit surprising, but all you need to do
is work around this behaviour is just enable
the u flag ES6 that automatically makes the
dot operator work the way we would expect
toit work in the first place.
Another thing that is effective is quantifiers,
they are things like the plus sign the question
mark, numbers wrapped in braces indicate howmany
times you want to repeat the previous part
of the regular expression, in this example
we're matching 2 consecutive A symbols. This
works as expected, if you are trying to do
the same thing using an astral symbol instead
it won't actually work, the result is now
false instead of true.
That is because without the new flag if a
quantifier follows an astral symbol, it only
applies tothe low surrogate of that symbol.
Asfaras JavaScript is concerned, this
is what that regular expression looks like.
You have the astral symbol represented by
a surrogate pair then thereis way easy to
see that quantifier simply applies to only
the last part of the surrogate pair not to
surrogate pair as a whole.
This again probably not what you want, or
what you would expect, but it's really easy
to fix this, all you needtodo is just
apply the u flag. This way quantifiers apply
to whole symbols even for astral symbols.
So it's the only way to make sure that JavaScript
treats all code points equally. I believe
that's part of the code of conduct at JSConfEU,
you are basically legally obliged to use the
u flag from now on. Other way that’s different
is character classes. Without the u flag any
given character class can only match a BMP
symbol, things like BCD work as expected they
match either B or C or D if you try to add
an astral symbol to that class the JavaScript
treats it again as two separate characters,
one for each half of the surrogate pair because
of that tetragram for symbol is not matched
this again is a little bit confusing Ithink.
So asfaras JavaScript is concerned this
is what regular expression looks like, the
character class contains not 3 but 4 characters,
and that is why the result is false instead
of true.
Now all you needtodo to fix it, well you
guessed it all you needtodois add the
u flag to regular expression and that magically
makes it work the way you expect toit, you
can now use a whole astral symbols in character
classes. Now this also means that the whole
astral symbols can be used in character class
ranges, and everything will still work the
way you would expect toit as long as the
u flag is set.
in this case I'm trying to create a range
from the pile of poo character to the busy
symbol, pile of poo and the busy symbol, it
works the way I would expect it to. However,
if you omit the a flag if you tried this in
ES 5 you would get an error. The regular
expression would throw and it would say the
range is out of order in the character class,
that happens again, because of the same behaviour
basically, so far as JavaScript is concerned
this is what that regular expression looks
like you are creating a range between two
astral symbols each represented by a surrogate
pair and JavaScript tries to create a range
between the first character and first surrogate
for the second one it's not the range you
wanted to create in the first place, the first
code point is a greater number than the second
one it also throws an error. Once again
just use the u flag and all the problems go
away automatically. Now the u flag
also effects negated character classes, so
for example, carat a character class matches
any BMP accept a, but not astral symbols JavaScript
considers those to be too separate characters.
With the u flag enabled the very same regular
expression now matches the best bigger set
of all Unicode symbols exceptfor a.
Now, character
class escapes are impacted as well, backslash,
lower case d, which matches any digit from
zero to 9, also backslash upper case D, matches
the set nothing that's not a digit 0 - 9,
white space characters, you can match, or
non-white space, backslash S for,/W, a word
charge defined as any character from A to
Z in lower case or upper case, underscore
or digit from 0 - 9. Now the
U flag affects the meaning of these character
class escapes with an upper case, so/d, /w,
without U+ flag these match any BMP symbol
not matched by the lower case counterparts,
so for example,/S, matches any non-white space
symbol, so it would match the character A
for example, but it wouldn't match an astral
symbol like tetragram for centre and that
is because once again those are considered
to be two separate characters in JavaScript,
this is probably not what you want. Now,
with the u flag enabled,/D, S and W, they
match astral symbols too which makes a lot
more sense. Now it's important to know that
in the verse counter points so the lower case
d, sand w, they're not affected at all by
the a flag, there was in fact a proposal on
ES discussed to change their meaning and make
them more Unicode aware,/d could match many
more digits in many scripts not just o- nine
in Arabic, but other scripts, but it was rejected
in favour of a bigger proposal I'll talk about
in a second.
Now there
is another gotcha with this, essentially the
act of converting upper case Unicode symbols
into lower case form, that's not just letters
A to Z, that's pretty simple, but actually
you need to be aware of different scripts,
different languages and Unicode standard defines
all these mappings for all the different code
points.
Now when
both the i flag for case insensitivity and
the a flag for Unicode are enabled, on the
same regular expression all the symbols are
implicitly case folded before being compared,
this might lead to surprising results every
now and then.
So for example,
the regular expression where you match the
range A to Z in lower case, you can enable
case insensitivity using the i flag, if you
now enable the u flag as well, suddenly you
will also match the code point oh 17 F, it
goes to the S, according to Unicode case folder,
same for A and 212 A, so this another one
of the things you need to watch out for and
it's another reason not just to blindly add
the a flag to your existing regular expressions
you might change their meaning this way.
The case
folding logic I mentioned applies to the symbols
in the regular expression pattern as well
as the symbols in the string to be matched,
so it goes both ways. In general that's
petty useful behaviour, but in some cases
it can be really, really confusing, for example,
by default /W, matches anything that is not
matched by/w, it matches any non-word character,
but when both the I and the u flag the case
folding logic kicks in, essentially, well,
/W which is supposed to match no word characters,
now matches the capital letter K and S, it's
probably weird, it's not what you would expect,
it's another thing to watch out for when you
are using the u flag and another reason not
to just blindly add to all your existing regular
expressions, make sure you are not using /W
first.
Now believe
it or not the existence of the a flag also
has its effect on HTML documents, the pattern
attribute for input or exterior elements,
allows you to - the browser then provides
with styling and scribing hooks to make stuff
happen on the validity of that input.
Now the
u flag is always enabled for regular expressions
compiled through HTML pattern, according to
the specification, la.w, use that as a pattern,
the dot operator well match astral symbols
as well, just like we discussed before.
Now what
about browser and engine support for new Unicode
features. Microsoft edge is the only stable
browser with implementation of it, they support
it in they Chakra engine, but not the HTML
pattern flag yet, however I filed a book on
that, I can assume that they are working on
it, also an experimental version available,
it's hidden behind the flag, you can play
around with it if you want to, there are a
few minor bugs, but we're working on it, what
about all the other browsers, it would be
a shame if we couldn't use u flag today, wouldn't
it, that's why I created RegExp, the ES 6
expressions using the u flag into ES 5 codes
that work day-to-day so you can start using
the u flag today, you may actually have noticed
that the Babel transpilers both support the
a flag as well, if you use a regular expression
with the u flag they will translate it into
ES 5 regular. The good news is if you are
using a transpiler as part of the build process
you don't have to do anything, you can start
using the u flag today.
Now, just
to give quickly give you an idea of how RegExPu
works internally, we need to borrow JavaScript
code, we need source code to put that into
abstract syntax tree, I used the esprima
parser for this. Then I look for regular
expressions, literals in that EST that have
the u flag enabled, once I found such a regular
expression, I parsed it, it self, using another
parser, - it was originally a regular expression
parser of course for this progress I needed
to support ECMA 6 as well, like the u flag
-
finally we rewrite each regular expression
without u flag so it's equivalent, but compatible
with ES5, I use regenerate for that and no
Unicode data, some data packages I will give
you an example of this later.
Then we update the regular expression abstract
syntax tree then we transform the regular
expression syntax tree back into regular expression
literal. You could use the GN project for
that. Then finally we update our original
JavaScript abstract tree soit contains the
new regular expression. I do this, it makes
it really easy, transforming the JavaScript
abstract syntax tree back into JavaScript
code. That's it at the end. We started out
with ES6 code that uses lots of ES6 features
and u flag for regular expression, at the
end ECMAScript 5 compatible code comes out.
Now for something that still no built in syntax
in ECMAScript 6 even with the u flag, forexample,
Unicode provides alot of data files for
categories, scripts, blocks and properties,
but there’s no way to access that data directly
in regular expressions. So forexample let's
say you wantto match allthe Unicode symptoms
inthe Greek script. One way to do this is
to use the third party library like exRegExp
that would look like this so you just use
the \p syntax, then between the braces you
can use the name of a property or a category
or a block, and exRegExp will care of that
for you. know the I am also parsing the character
a there, a flag that stands for astral symbol
support, a custom flag that it makes it really
easy to match all Greek symbols. There’s
only one down side to this, it's that exRegExp
is a 35kb runtime, it may not be the best
solution in performance critical situations.
There's another way of coming up with a similar
result, you could just build a script use
the regenerate library I talked about earlier.
That would look something like this, so you
write a script like that you require, regenerate,
then you use the node Unicode data modules
that basically contain arrays of Unicode symbols
and points. I am gettingan array containing
allthe symbols and the Greek scripts according
to Unicode version 6.30, I am parsing that
array into regenerate. That gives me a set
of characters or code points and then I turn
that into a regular expression or, well actually
a string I can use as part of a regular expression
literal. It gives me this result. Again this
not a regular expression that I would enjoy
writing out by hand let alone testing it or
maintaining it. You may have noticed I am
actually using an outdated Unicode version
here, this is version 6.3.0, but the latest
version is version 8. Imagine having to update
this regular expression manually without having
this build script of 4 lines it would be alot
of work. Now I have the small scripts, allI
needtodo is change the version number,
run the script again, just like that an up-to-date
regular expression comes out.
Now, hopefully ina future version of ECMAScript
there willbe built in support for the \p
syntax that Pearl already supports, that way
you could already use \p to match allthe
symbols inthe Greek script, then it would
just work as long as you use the u flag. The
thing is everyone agrees it's a very big proposal,
everyone wants to do this but the problem
is that someone needs to do the work and write
the specification for it so if you are interested
in that come talk to me afterwards, we'll
make it happen.
Anyway, the main takeaways here are you should
use the u flag when you can for all the regular
expressions you write from now on. Ithink
remember the u flag is to regular expression
as strict mode is to all of JavaScript.
Now, you also shouldnot blindly add the
u flag to your existing regular expression,
you might accidentally change their meaning
in very subtle ways that might actually break
your code. Finally, we should use a transpiler,
because this way your ES6 code runs everywhere.
You shouldn't just use a transpiler for these
particular features but for many other features
as well, ofcourse Babel and Tracer, they
both already support transpilation of the
u flag thanksto RegExpu. Whenever you need
a regular expression based on some unicode category or a property or a script, you should just write
a simple build script that use regenerate
and build it and use xRegExpat runtime. Thank you.
There is a blogpost at that URL which basically details the same
thing I talked about in this presentation,
enjoy.